did it hypocritical of Congress to
repeal the health care reform bill but
not their own government health care now
I don't know how you can defend that
it's not hypocritical it's hypocritical
do you think they should repeal both
repeal both really you think they should
have given up their health care yeah I
think the cut Congress to give up their
pension their health care elbows Thanks
thank you popular on Capitol a head of
Obama's address next Tuesday what would
you say the state of our union is it's
in bad shape and the reason for it is
that we've been living high on the hog
beyond our means for 30 years borrowing
like there's no tomorrow consumers the
government and now we're at the point
where we got to start paying our bills
and I think he ought to tell the
American public we're all in this
together we're going to have to make
some sacrifices and that needs to start
at the top I think that we're in bad
shape because the way that we solve our
problems is sort of cramped there needs
to be a fight about different ways to
approach the country's problems in which
both sides are actually proposing real
policies that would go some distance
toward fixing those problems and we're
having two different debates one thing
about what the Democrats want to do and
the other side is about how the
Democrats are evil and we need to have
two different takes on how to fix
problems in the country we don't have
that I want to you know I feel like the
dialogue has been so in dissin genuine
and it's simple I could call it recently
I had a conversation of a jail that's
piqued him all the time I don't I don't
agree with anything I'm far to the left
personally I'm Dennis Kucinich hey my
[ __ ] is way he's too mad I feel but I
but I feel dialogue is important and I
think the president could come into a
reasonable season if there was genuine
dialogue
I talked to Roger I said one of the
things that he has to get done is prison
reform these people and the being
they're a disease they go to jail they
come home and they trained in criminal
behavior they destroy communities we
cannot let this happen this has to
change and here's a guy who was like
completely ignorant to that I didn't he
says well [ __ ] put somebody else putting
somewhere else now I'd prefer to send
two homes and no rehab he said give him
a TV his Rajal says give him a TV right
put him somewhere
they're in a population if there's a
violent population where they know what
he meant was put them somewhere else
give them an opportunity to rehab
somewhere else where do you see jail but
it's not the same jail where they don't
get trained in criminal behavior and
that solves your problem well if you
have no choice where is your thing and
you're saying roger ailes i every time
I'm in trouble I had to call him for
whatever reason is I get I talk I call
everybody I get along with everyone I
get along with Trevor
[Laughter]
15-minute interview that I wouldn't you
know cut properly for the three minutes
right I needed him to fix that right I
said what I wanted to say but it was a
fun discussion but anyway the point I'm
making this we had a compromise there
was a compromise they put him somewhere
else and then there's the kind of
dialogue we have in the next four years
in this country I hope he meant rehab
just like the lame duck clearly wants it
to be in an appliance store I don't know
I use I put him in another part of the
prison that is more like a rehab and
where they have a different kind of
treatment and where they don't you know
they don't have to integrate with a
violent population and become criminals
and that's kind of an answer it's not
the one I wanted but I'll take it and
that's what the president has to be able
to do let me tell you something attends
you this question that was asked about
the State of the Union and you said you
both said it's not good there was a
president once who said that Gerald Ford
once started a State of the Union
address by saying the state of our
nation is not good
unimaginable unimaginable today and
that's part because of your boyfriend
Ronald Reagan well Jimmy Carter instant
necessity to blow sunshine up the ass of
the American people no president a
Republican thank you but but they need
said they were in deep doo-doo I mean
people don't want to hear that from you
baby they don't want to hear it but
don't people need to hear things as
opposed to what they want yet they need
the truth but you know what will the
truth is we are in deep [ __ ]
Adam is getting better we're gonna get
more jobs you know we've got a
Republican Congress now coming a month
when he took office and how many we not
losing the army one more question do you
think the amount of news coverage given
to the Martin Luther King Day bombing
attempt in Spokane Washington was fair I
don't
it's amazing the FBI that was Times
Square yeah exactly the head of the FBI
office in Spokane says this is the most
this is a very serious bomb could have
killed a lot of people is the real deal
this was not a fake other law
enforcement sources are saying it's the
most sophisticated bomb they've ever
seen in the United States Wow and it was
on an MLK Day parade and it was put in
the right spot to kill a lot of people
it was almost an accident as found we
sent us 250 agents now to Tucson Arizona
why is this a whodunit our country the
way always fighting the last war always
blowing a giant force at a problem that
doesn't need it there we're fighting the
wrong war the whole border is now open
criminal warfare because of the drug
laws and if we got rid of the drug laws
half of this problem would abate a great
gun violence would abate as well I'm the
chairman of foundations we have to gonna
stay at research in this country have
been moving in a more tolerant direction
for 10 straight years this year we took
a giant step backwards and with the
amount of Islamophobia with the growing
anti-semitism with the black white white
black all of it has gone backwards and
this is I don't know if it's a direct
response to someone say President Obama
someone say it's poverty some for a lot
of reasons I'm gonna stay with the Tea
Party and someone say was Fox News I
mean someone they say different [ __ ]
but it is really the truth that we are
going to tolerance level is going takes
one second for things that shift you
know what unimaginable horrors can
happen when a country takes this kind of
shift and as quickly and as violently as
it has all right let's go get high with
Roger oh well on Mexico more people were
killed on Mexican drug violence last
year than in Afghanistan Iraq combined
well that's that's to me quite telling
and we're sort of ignoring it we're
pretending it's not happening goes to
this point of you know it's all it's all
being in Cabo
[Applause]